hello good late afternoon
here don't really thank you because this
is the last talk of the day it's after
30 minute break got you all you know
loaded up on choc tops so thanks hope
this is interesting to you hope we can
like explode brains in a kind of a new
and different way in this last talk so
let's get started I'm Caleb I'm
currently a software architect I've
worked at the same company for six years
it's called open X it's an ad exchange
in Southern California Pasadena I was a
JavaScript engineer there for five years
and then I just transitioned to oh no
screensaver alright just gotta bring up
my speaker notes again well looks like
we exited presentation mode so let's
just go with this right so I'm an
architect now which means I get to fix
all the code dead I created for myself
starting in 2012 and we're gonna talk
about taming the world's largest Trojan
horse so let's start with digital
advertising and actually I'm curious how
many of you work directly in AD
technology okay it's like 10 15 people
how many of you in the course of your
jobs have to interact with that
technology or work on platforms that are
you know monetize using digital ads okay
so good good portion let's define some
terms media advertising what is that
so we have marketers and we have
audience right marketers are people with
goods and services you know that they
want to sell to an audience now they're
like many ways to go about it like one
less efficient way to do that would be
to just like list out all the people in
the world and go up to them one by one
and ask them that they wanted to buy
this thing right that's not super
efficient and so we have something
called media advertising which is where
the marketer actually gets to the
audience by way of something that we
call a publisher which is someone who
has some kind of like attention real
estate right so it could be a magazine
could be a billboard could be a website
something that the marketer can go to
and say hey let me place my ad on the
thing that all the people are looking at
anyway right and we have brokers which
are basically you know companies people
who are aggregating the markets you know
taking what we call the demand on the
one side and the supply on the other and
connecting it and the money is gonna
flow from left to right in this diagram
that's media advertising and here's a
number for you across the world globally
in 2017 marketers spent half a trillion
dollars five hundred eighty four billion
dollars spent on media advertising last
year that's a lot so there's a subset of
media advertising that I want to talk
about for this talk and that's called
digital display advertising so it's the
same diagram but the players are just
kind of like subsets of what they were
before our audience is Internet users
people who are you know connected to the
Internet somehow and the marketers are
pretty much the same marketers but
they're tapping into Internet connected
audiences I may have to do this every
five minutes so I don't shut down again
our publishers our digital display
publishers as we call and they're folks
who run publications that are connected
to the Internet and that you know have
screens right so desktop web app
websites what mobile apps mobile web
connected TVs anything that has a screen
with some pixel real estate that can
show display ads and is connected to the
Internet and the broker is digital
display ad tech that's the industry I
work in here's a pie chart that kind of
gives some higher fidelity to that ad
spend a number of five hundred eighty
four billion and we can kind of break it
down all the blue stuff I highlight
because that's kind of a bigger category
called digital in general and it's like
all Internet connected advertising so it
includes things like search classified
ads the display category is right here
right and that's 19% of a whole pie I'm
just going to check if
thing has a laser pointer do we know if
it has a laser pointer no okay I wonder
if the person let me borrow it is here
so the blue stuff right what's
interesting about this pie chart is that
2017 marks the first year that the
digital category actually eclipse TV
right so the first time ever traditional
TV ad spend was at 35% if you add these
together I think it's 40% that's
unprecedented right so this is a very
large growing category and digital
display which we're talking about today
is the largest chunk within digital this
is a very confusing picture right this
is the display loom escape and it's kind
of used in ad tech talks to kind of like
wave in front of people and say look how
complicated digital display is right and
it's really complicated all right so
this is the same kind of flow as the
previous diagram where you have
marketers on one side and publishers and
the audience on the other side except
all these are actually companies that
are you know together they constitute
digital display ad tech it's a lot of
companies you can see the the dashed
lines denote acquired company shuttered
companies everyone's kind of merging and
splitting and growing my company is
right there it's in this middle box
OpenX may be hard to see but we're in ad
exchange which means we sit pretty much
smack in the middle of this huge wall of
money that's moving across right and you
know I'd like to say this really
indicates like the the you know how
thriving in this industry is right
there's so much movement so many players
everyone's kind of jumping up with their
startup trying to get a piece of the pie
let's talk about some numbers for
digital display 110 marketing dollars
spent 110 billion marketing dollars
spent right so if you backed out the
math from the 19 percent of the 584 it's
about 110 users reached on the order of
a billion if we just go by Facebook's
last stat about their monthly active
users which is 2.2 billion we know
they're all seeing digital ads so we're
talking about like large percentages of
the entire
world population that's being reached by
digital display and then something
called
ad impression which is really just like
the occurrence of an ad like getting
from an ad server onto one of these
publications
I asked me about 10 trillion of those
happened in 2017 and you know you could
say if each of these you know three or
four billion people had a thousand ads
served to them over the course of the
year that's a reasonable number right 10
10 trillion times that an ad was
actually shown to someone or marketed to
someone and that brings us the kind of
the point of this talk and why you know
this is at J esketh and not at you know
on a an ad tech yacht in the South of
France right 10 trillion 10 trillion
right this number
why is it important how do you how do
you get stuff how do you get arbitrary
images to show up on websites and web
apps and mobile apps and stuff
JavaScript right so 10 trillion is the
number of times that JavaScript based
ads rendered right and you could say oh
well what about mobile app right that's
not really most of these things are done
in web views in mobile apps right so
this this we should be proud of this
right JavaScript engineers are helping
you know they're the gatekeepers of this
enormous unprecedent unprecedented
industry half a trillion dollars so
round of applause please all of you are
involved in this somehow right this
community is powering this kind of
industry and now we get to this metaphor
that that the talk is built around this
Trojan horse right so what happens when
you combine a hundred and ten billion
dollars of economic pressure with a
platform that can deliver arbitrary HTML
on to properties all across the world
right inevitably some bad things get
through right and you know I've invoked
the Trojan horse metaphor so I need to
qualify myself which is you know it's
typically a Trojan horse is we think of
it as being maliciously designed right
so ad technology isn't you know doesn't
have a malicious thought behind it
however what I am interested in is
the idea that it's kind of a
nice-looking container for literally
anything right so any code can come and
run on a web page or a mobile app and so
you know we as JavaScript engineers are
actually you know we're were the
gatekeepers to this kind of thing and we
have the challenge of you know how do we
deal with all these kind of latent
consequences and undesirable code and
things that are running everywhere and
that's a really challenging thing and
that's what I want to share with you
today so the talk is structured in three
parts construction payload and inversion
and I'll explain what these seconds are
and we get to them part one construction
we're going to talk about some really
basic building blocks of digital display
AdTech right and these are just
JavaScript concepts that we're all
probably familiar with but they've kind
of taken on meanings that they're in the
ad tech world and when you put them all
together then I think we'll have a
better understanding of you know what
I'm talking about
first is this thing called an ad tag
right this is just some arbitrary markup
that's usually handed from you know some
ad tech company down this way in the
supply chain right to a publisher so
that they can put it on their page and
when they put it on their like an ad
shows up right and it's typically in two
parts we have something where there's
like some configuration like declared in
JavaScript you know this is the site
that I'm coming from these are the sizes
that I want to allow in this little box
and then there's a call-out to a script
that's typically called an ad TAC right
or sorry a tag library so this is a
hosted script that's hosted by you know
on some CDN by some ad tech company and
it's going to download the JavaScript
that's going to interpret the
configuration and kick off what we call
like an ad request right the process of
sending an HTTP request out of the
browser and getting an ad back now
what's important and you can see I've
kind of highlighted on this second line
HTML grabbing some property out of the
ad response object and that hTML is you
know it's it's also kind of arbitrary
markup if we think of ad tag
is kind of like a delivery mechanism
then iframes are in AdTech a containment
mechanism right so we can say I want to
drop some like random markup from
someone way up the supply chain into
this little sandbox and we use iframes
for that and this is a very
oversimplified example because there are
tons of edge cases that come in for
different browsers and different
situations with subdomains and all this
and typically if you write a tag library
this is gonna be one of the larger
functions and you're just gonna like a
creep like you know arcane knowledge of
how to do iframes
over the years now if you combine add
tags and iframes what you get is the
possibility of like you can actually
traffic an ad tag as the ad responds to
HTML and you can kind of have like
never-ending chains where like what
you're actually loading as your ad is
not an image but it's like another tag
that calls out and calls out and like we
see these like seven or eight levels
deep sometimes just because how many
people are actually involved in getting
an ad to show up to more as far as
construction goes cookies right we know
and love cookies in AD text they're used
primarily to identify users consistently
so here's some code of you know a
JavaScript based cookie but you can also
do this on the server side you know a
server can declare that it wants to set
a cookie the idea is that it gets to
store a little bit of information on
behalf of its domain in the in the
user's browser and we can use this to
consistently identify a user based on
some unique ID this would be like a
tracking mechanism and then the last one
is like an analytics mechanism we have
what we call pixels which is a misnomer
but it came from this idea that you
could just kind of serve an image
element that would contain some some
like query yards and when that image was
was requested it would return like a 1x1
hidden jiff right and you basically just
be using the fact that you could render
an image but also sneak some get
variables like back to your servers and
you could have some idea of like what
happened as an ad tech company you could
say oh I know that the person actually
saw the ad
and you know I know that the impression
ID was one two three four five now we do
this more programmatically with
JavaScript this is an example from the
kind of recent navigator dot send beacon
API where we we have the flexibility to
kind of construct a little bit more as
far as like the you know things we'd
like to send back all right so I'm gonna
borrow from the popular mean form mean
format to kind of like round out the the
picture of like what it's like to view a
JavaScript ad tech developer blanks are
like the most unspecific way of
reporting a bug but you have to deal
with them all the time right dad's not
showing up it's blank what do I do I
have to go debug I have to go you know
like a me this morning and be digging
around all inside the network tab and
find out why is the ad not showing up
your code versus third-party code this
is like battle bots right when you write
JavaScript and put it out there on the
web you have no idea who else is going
to be running in that global variable
soup I once had a bug where like there
was literally a library that was the
name the same as mine and was like
confusing like you know variables
stepping all over each other you have to
write your JavaScript code really
defensively when you're an ad tech
Network tab you know you're gonna be
there for days like Network Tabak is
like burned into my retinas is like a
physical location like I've been there
you know should work in all browsers
this is a big one right because it
doesn't matter if Internet Explorer 7
was sunsetted you know five years ago
it's still a big enough percentage of
110 billion dollars that you got to deal
with it you will be reading lots of
minified code you may break a major
website and have to wake up and deal
with it basically don't merge code on
Fridays because you don't want to work
on the weekend and then in the ad tech
version of the waiting for it to compile
trick you can pretty much look at any
website you want and just say that
you're you're debugging it all right
part two so what kinds of things are
actually coming through right this is
broken down into three hashtags first is
whoops right what are the kind of
undesirable things they're kind of
benign alright you have like a really
nice clean template of a site and it's
grayscale and modern and then your ad
comes in right and it's like it makes
your eyes bleed right you have no
control over that
you know autoplay audio and video right
this is a great one you ever like you
know like got your head down you're
working you know you got your Spotify
going and then there's like this weird
voice that's like you're like that's not
part of the song you know what's going
on yeah autoplay audio and video coming
through adds block list violation so
you're like this little guy and your
plan minion rush and then all of a
sudden ad comes in that kind of like
challenges your worldview right you know
that's not what my parents told me and
you freaked out right so this is like an
ad quality block list violation right
these are just things we're like the
person who runs this game this mobile
game probably didn't want that to come
through and maybe even if they indicated
that it still came through our solution
as JavaScript engineers is to build
feedback loops right so we've we kind of
turned to another skill that we have as
front engineers which is like building
user interfaces and these are some
pictures from one of our tool suites
called it's called add protection
basically we allow you know users to
report an ad that they think is
inappropriate and then we aggregate you
know these complaints and from you know
aggregate results from large scale
scanners that are actually trying to
render these like on the server side and
also allow them to be forwarded to
people more on this side of the supply
chain right so if they came from other
buyers that we like as an exchange as
open X that we deal with we have a tool
that kind of lets us you know forward
the information to the right party right
and so we're we're using our our UX and
front-end
skills as JavaScript engineers to build
these kinds of tools that create
feedback loops the second one is just
which is like I take to mean just like
general low-quality things that ads
cause to happen sometimes so here's one
where you know I was trying to click on
a blog post and then you know before I
could click this ad came in and you know
no offense to the folks at SendGrid
they're great but I didn't want to go
there right I wanted to go to the blog
post and this is like technically
actually called PageRank it's when the
page is actually re-rendering itself
some people call it reflow but you have
no control over the code that comes
through as part of this arbitrary add
markup right and so it makes the page do
weird things sometimes large files I
can't even like bear to look at this all
right but no one's gonna keep you from
making your your ad image like 50
megabytes and so here's another one HTTP
request party right what if you just
what if your add markup comes in and
just has tons of requests and this is
actually from a tool that we built it's
called add footprint it's a chrome dev
tools extension you can download it on
the chrome store and it kind of breaks
things up by what types of requests are
actually happening on a page it's kind
of like lighthouse for AdTech we break
it up into content and then add requests
so there's initial requests that are
going out of the browser and then ad
slots like the requests that come from
stuff within that first level of iframes
that gets written out and this kind of
has a problem right so we dig in go to
ad slots we categorize all the ad slots
on the page and look this 970 by 250 is
having problems right 12 12 seconds to
load so we click in there and we can see
basically there's 36 requests that's a
lot probably don't need that many and
there's this one one by one jiff right
here that's taken almost half a second
to load so the solution to this problem
of Jake eNOS I think aside from building
tools that let you understand it is to
make performance repeatable right for
publishers and people building websites
in general what if we had something that
would do all these things
and if you've spoken to the folks
outside at the MP table this is actually
just shamelessly copied from their
website right this this is what amp does
it kind of is a restricted way of
writing HTML that includes some
performance guarantees and what's nice
about this is not only that it's kind of
relegating ads away from the main thread
and making your content great but
there's also like amp for ATS right so
you can start to specify your ads amp
documents as well and this is really
cool I think we as a community like have
recently started thinking more about
performance a lot of the talks today and
yesterday we're focused on performance
and if we kind of aggregate knowledge
into open source projects like like amp
we're gonna make the web better and
we're gonna solve Jake eNOS even if it
comes from third parties the last one is
shadiness right finger printing so
finger printing looks kind of benign
it's this is from an open-source version
of a finger printer from three years ago
it's basically collecting a bunch of
random things about what's happening in
the browser and creating a unique string
out of them so what's the big deal about
that well basically there's enough like
kind of entropy in all the different
settings and things in in a browser that
you can kind of mash them together and
create a consistent unique ID for that
environment
aka user and basically if third-party
cookies are turned off you can
consistently identify the user that's
kind of shady right if user doesn't want
to be tracked you shouldn't be tracking
them but this stuff comes through right
it adds sometimes force redirects are
one that's kind of been taken the
industry by storm last couple years
you're on a mobile site and then
suddenly you're in the App Store
right and there's not really much you
can do about it and this is because an
ad came through that you know kind of
exploited some some holes in the browser
and was able to open the app store and
try and get you to download something
that you didn't want here's one that's
top of mind all right so on January 24th
of this year the number of coin hive
miners went up 300
percent all the sudden right and what
was happening was that someone was if
using the double-click ad server to
insert some web mining code into ads
that were going all over the Internet
and you know getting free coins and this
is just an example of like what we call
malvert izing right it's people who were
actually doing nefarious things in
abusing the fact that ad tech delivers
arbitrary code our solution is to like
build tools that not only render ads and
see what they look like and create those
feedback loops but actually try to
understand at a more of a semantic level
what's happening right like who called
who and what did they actually do so
this comes from our data protection
suite and it's showing you a diagram of
like basically tag calls right so this
is from the open XCOM web page home page
and there's like a Google tag manager
there's not gonna be a lot of ad tech
stuff here but you can kind of get the
sense that like the Google tag manager
was called and then it loaded a few
other things right the Google Analytics
dynamic remarketing some various things
and this gives us a sense like starts to
give us a sense of like who's actually
doing what on web pages and we've also
done some work actually analyzing the
code that comes through and here we've
classified a bunch of add tags that
rendered on a page and given them
indexes as far as security data sharing
user tracking tag chaining by actually
like looking at the code that they
deliver and trying to understand it and
this is something that kind of like only
JavaScript engineers can do because
we're the ones who understand what
JavaScript code looks like and something
that's really cool is that we've
implemented a container that I that if
you load tags through the container on
your page you can actually block
specific behaviors that arbitrary code
may try to do so you can you can
actually turn off you know HTML cookie
writing or reading local storage and a
number of other things you can just
block those behaviors if you want I
think it's pretty cool so the last and
quick part of my talk is just like
some thoughts about you know where's
this going what can we as a JavaScript
community do to make things better
here's some here's some thoughts right
so this is from the the data protection
tool this is a particularly egregious
example of just the spam enos of ads
right so this is a homepage the tag
chain diagram of a real you know widely
used newspaper website 1665 tags and
pixels that collect data do other things
from a total of 114 different vendors
right this is like crazy this is like
way too much stuff another thought I saw
this on Twitter just a couple days ago
some people taking advantage of a new
feature called HSTs which is meant to
help you make secure calls more often
and they exploited the fact that it
stored some new information in the
browser and they were using it to do
fingerprinting and this person says I
hate how the web has devolved into a war
between bad actors and advertising and
engineers who are trying to push the
state of web tech forward so these these
last two pictures right they're just
meant to make us think okay so we can
kind of be in this arms race against
people doing bad things and an arms race
against undesirable janky whoopsy kind
of ads but where is the web going
because of all this right are we getting
to a place where it's kind of like this
picture which is an artist rendition
from later on our 2014 ein where if you
saw that movie there's like ads
everywhere right they're plastered all
over buildings in every possible square
inch of available space and not only
that they're like highly targeted to the
person walking down the street like the
ad starts talking to the guy right is
this the world that we kind of want to
move to right is this where all the
economic pressure is forcing us I want
to suggest not and specifically I want
to bring to our attention this idea of
something called a native ad now it has
a pretty plain definition native
advertising is a type of advertising
mostly online that matches the form and
function of the platform upon which it
appears now here are a couple examples
of thing
that have been maybe mistaken for being
native ads but they're not quite there
first one is you know these kind of like
from around the web boxes that we often
see at the bottom of reading an article
where you're like oh that looks
interesting oh wait you're right that's
not from no the people who wrote the
article that I just read so it's kind of
hiding some people call that native not
really it may look like the content and
do a good job of getting people to click
on it it's not just returning your ad
with JSON so instead of returning markup
and just rendering it how it comes it's
you know natives sometimes people think
oh that's just you know JSON and then
you need some actual code on the front
end to like parse it and do stuff with
it native ads may involve JSON as a
response night but not necessarily and
then there's this format that's coming
around where you're kind of scrolling
through a page and then like all of a
sudden like it kind of slides open and
there's a video playing native is not
just camel flage that's right
or as it kind of jump out at you and
scare you right so what is native done
and this is my last slide it's just a
picture of three ads that I think could
be considered native and helped us you
know see how we can get away from that
possible dystopian future this is from
my blog right and I have a small blog I
write technical articles on it I run it
on digitalocean servers and so I put
this like link on there and a couple
years ago because digitalocean has like
a referral program and now the blog is
paying for itself right and it I think
it matches the form and function of the
site on which it it lives here's one
from a publication called The Verge
where I I'm pretty sure this is an ad
I'm not sure but duolingo can now teach
you how to speak Klingon and it's like
you know it's got the same style and you
know colors and stuff and like you know
that's interesting to me as the reader
of the verge and so it matches the form
and function and then last of all you
know Twitter is a great example right
because they're monetizing through the
very format that the the the platfor
was famous for which is tweets right and
I just saw this the other day I thought
it was interesting you know that United
actually used a promoted tweet to tell
people that they had a network outage
and are working to get the system's back
online right that's that's pretty cool
right because this indicates that the
way that the platform was monetized has
now become like a general purpose
messaging and targeting platform and I
think that's that's really cool
and so just final thought is that native
is hard because what works on my blog
doesn't work on the verge and doesn't
work on Twitter and vice versa right and
so it requires the engineers you and I
who actually work on these publications
to do some hard thinking and have some
hard conversations about how to make
these things viable businesses without
you know selling out four clicks right
and I think that we're all more than
capable of doing that and in the process
making the internet a much better place
so thank you
[Applause]
you